[Applause]
oh
16 please
left wing mob shutting down free speech
again over a hundred people including
members of antifa hurling eggs smashing
windows and trying to disrupt the
Charlie Kirk event at UC Davis so how
can you be mad at Charlie Kirk the
violence leading to two arrests and one
police officer was injured the young
conservative leader telling Prime Time
how it all went down
the core issue is that these college
campuses we know that they become
radical we know that they're no longer
places of Free Speech but a speaker on
American college campus if you want to
come and talk about free speech and
American values it should not be a
danger to fellow students or to the
speaker over a hundred police officers
were there last night that mob was there
to try to do violence the war on free
speech is having a chilling effect on
education listen to what this former
Professor had to say about it
it doesn't really matter if you're in
the tribe or not if you say something
wrong that's enough to get you
essentially ostracized and kicked out
and so I think everybody walks on
eggshells we're literally moving away
from the foundations of Academia
did this happen when you were in college
I was trying to think about that today
because we this guy uh that Professor
he'll be on America's Newsroom tomorrow
he's a science teacher so he and he
feels so much that he had to self-censor
that he would rather leave a job that he
loves and pursue something else because
he doesn't want to have to be a part of
that anymore and I was trying I was
thinking back to the professors that I
have there's this one oh gosh what's his
name Paula Paula something I can picture
her but she taught political science and
I never knew what her politics were but
she would stir the pot and get everybody
going and it was so invigorating and so
fun and so no I I don't recall and
especially I was in Southern Colorado
cooking class political science oh you
said she was stirring the pot yeah
that's a little phrase Paula Deen she
was the person there you go
what was her name well when you think
about it just let us know yeah let us
know before we just wait here and wait
I'm not done I'm done I'm done Greg
while she thinks about the professor
that she doesn't remember I had an
interesting Epiphany last night when I
was thinking about this story because we
were we did it on my show the students
are bad but the teachers are worse
because where do the students get this
stuff from they get it from their
teachers so you have adults that are
advocating for a behavior that adults
with tenure can endure but
students kids they can't succeed on this
Behavior right it's like when you look
at a successful well-known celebrities
who parade their pronouns on Twitter
it's deceptive because the only
successful woke people were successful
first right so you have Lady Gaga with
her pronouns but she was Lady Gaga first
students however think that oh these are
these successful people buy into this
woke stuff so shall I that it doesn't
work that way it's like it's like drugs
it's like you don't do drugs until
you're successful or you never will be
successful and in this case it's like if
you get a resume with somebody with
their pronouns on it you're not gonna
you're not gonna interview that person
but that person is just merely emulating
something that they learn from adults
who can endure such stupid Behavior what
if these people do become moderately
successful Harold and then go on to
become lawyers and and and and start
screwing around with the legal system
and railroading conservatives find ones
like myself yeah I would agree you are
you're a good one here's the thing
intellectual diversity
I remember when I was in college in in
law school and even high school we we
came together to challenge our school to
teach more American history and to teach
more world history in a world history
class we had at my high school in DC and
they allowed us to come before the the
board at the school that made those
decisions the academic board and we had
a great back and forth they challenged
us we challenged them and over a period
of time they began to open up the
curriculum in many ways and it's
enriched the school we had it at Penn we
had these huge brawls and we brought
people when I say brought intellectual
bras today they want to brawl physically
they want to brawl violently if you
can't entertain and sit and have a
substantive and good debate about with
someone whom you disagree with you're
not gonna be a good lawyer you may not
get into a good law school and if you do
because I think the standards are
changing everywhere God forbid what's
going to happen to the country if we
don't understand that you can just
disagree with someone but like them a
lot you can think their argument does
not measure up but you can continue to
have debates in conversation the thing I
worry most about is they're professors
and their uh those in the executive
Executives at these schools who are
promoting this and coddling these kids
we've talked about this this is my point
it's because they profit after it but
the students don't the student none of
those students you would ever hire they
could never work on the five if they if
they can't tolerate other opinions but
here's the thing we're balkanizing
they'll be able to find a job somewhere
where that Viewpoint is held and we
never ever figure out a way to get
together to say look you you have an
opinion I have an opinion let's debate
about it and just like you and I in the
last segment when it comes to
reparations if you put together an
education package and an Economic
Opportunity package you might be able to
agree we might be able to find a
majority to your point that last segment
I'm still bothered by it because it's
the most divisive thing you could do to
try to solve a real problem and this is
a symptom of it what we're saying at
these colleges I don't mean interrupted
judge no you were going and that's
exactly where I would start it is
divisive and that's what the left has
been doing it started about what seven
years ago when uh where was it at
Berkeley when somebody went to speak
there Milo Europa whatever his name was
and they were they wanted to burn down
the school nobody got arrested they
smashed windows and ironically it's it's
the beginning of free speech and
considered Berkeley but these people you
know when you look at the corporations
that gave money to Black lives matter
those corporations are being run by the
kids who've gone through these schools
and we talked about this before they
have gone up the ladder they are big
deals in some of these corporate uh
businesses and so they are already there
the question is are they they're in the
in the justice system not yet but
they're getting there and the left is
creating this Division and this hate
forget about how can you possibly do
that in law school the first amendment
is about free speech and freedom of
press right now people who are
assaulting other people alleging
defamation on the part of Charlie Kirk
saying he hates trans and and I mean
that is just a lie it's defamation
nobody's doing anything about it except
that they're apologizing but what's
happening now is that a lot of young
students are recognizing that college is
nothing but a lot of nonsense and they
are turning away from college and
they're turning toward apprenticeships
and apparently apprenticeships have
increased by more than 50 percent in the
United States since the pandemic and
there are now almost a million
apprentices in the in the past few years
and colleges are suffering the worst uh
uh uh uh uh uh what am I looking for the
the uh brain drain whatever in in sense
of pandemic so everything has changed
the young students know that they are
purposely choosing uh apprenticeships
over uh over colleges and so they're
recalibrating they don't want to be a
part this craziness they want to be able
to make money because when these people
get out of college they're not going to
be able to make money anyway does this
make you think differently about
marrying a black man in San Francisco uh
well well
I'm not going to San Francisco under any
circumstances so yes and if you want to
be judge jeanine's Apprentice contact us
I want to Brian Kilmeade I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now